we're here to see the collection we
built with GQ and the gap for the first
time
today we are fitting all of the looks
that we've styled out for the campaign
shoot as well as a lookbook shoot which
is the first time we're ever doing that
and it's exciting moment because each of
the designers really gets to get
up-close personal with the pieces for
the gap I'm really excited to see it all
come together you know it's really cool
about all the highs and the lows
they just keep adding up so this one
makes it that much more special because
it's it's another like boost of momentum
the really kind of fulfilling moment
when you're designing something over the
course of so many months to really kind
of see it materialize today will be the
first time that I get to see the entire
collection laid out and I'm excited I'm
ready to go in it's a big day this is
really the moment when it all comes
together these are the final pieces
there's no turning back at this point
teller
yeah Johnny Lee was so excited he went
right to the nucleus of the John le
wardrobe which is the hoodie with the
side zip
he was just blown away by what the gap
was able to do it's impressive the
zippers feel great they sound awesome
sue he was really happy with the sound
of the zipper and well oiled yeah we
just think it's amazing they're amazing
yeah John Moore went crazy over the
washes and the fabrics like the tonality
and on the brown he's really good
he was really really excited about how
the chinos turned out we always do this
tape trim in our trunks
we've never done it a pair of trousers
there's a lot of things that got brought
into this that we haven't done in the
main line so it's exciting to see this
interpretation it's great nylon it's
better in not just the fact that the
pieces had his attitude I love it
it's a good feeling to see it come to
life
yeah it's look great the exciting thing
is that it's done so smoothing it's been
so positive
he was really blown away by the
fabrications he felt it was really a
perfect storm it just clicks and then
the fits are right customer can walk
into the gap and buy each piece from my
collection and have a very complete
wardrobe that you can interchange it's
really a fulcrum cord rope you get
dressed in the dark they executed
everything way beyond my expectations
use overall impressed mostly with the
details even the zippers in the trim day
and then the construction overall right
down to the lifesaver snaps the way the
snaps come together they dialed it in
exactly how we dial it in and it was
really important because that's the way
we shine through our garments is through
these fine details the custom metal tip
heavier chunkier military-type zipper to
see gap be able to execute that for us
was amazing but you're happy oh it's
been an amazing process just to see it
all come together yeah yeah this is
we didn't know what was going to be like
to sit down at the tiny tiny little
company with one of the biggest
retailers in the world the beginning I
told them I said don't worry about a gap
version of what you do do what you do on
the walk off this is thus they want it
to be you your DNA about some percent
and then they'll find a way to do it and
they did so this is our man line and
then this is the gapper they've done an
incredible job looks great they really
nailed it
how's it feel Chad it benefits all of us
if the clothes when they're hanging the
gap look like John Eliot er and more
Brooklyn tailors or em kneading they
look like the clothes that the designers
are known for then we've all done our
job on the wall plus cab
to see the johnelliott times gap on
tagged children
it's been an overwhelming response of
positivity from all of them this is the
next level next level yeah so far about
a thousand